There's my guy.
Welcome home.
This place is overwhelming.
Dr. Isabel Clemens pioneered brain box simulations,...
...ugly, simulated worlds to generate appreciation for the real world.
I'm glad I caught you.
Word on the street is there have been problems with Isabel's research.
I'm a little disoriented.
You're my guy.
Dad!
Graduation.
I did not forget.
It's been a crazy few days.
I graduated two weeks ago.
Ignore her.
She's not real.
She feels real.
I'm scared.
Your head's not on straight.
It's almost like a trick being played.
One of these days, you're going to have to choose between these worlds.
It's amazing how easy humans can get used to even something spectacular.